and finally new rule if 21st century
America really is a service economy and
I guess it is
since 80% of American jobs are in the
service industry somebody has to tell me
then why does the service here suck so
bad if we're the service people why am I
still on hold with Eastern Airlines last
week a recording went viral of a Comcast
customer service rep arguing endlessly
with a customer who just wanted to
cancel his service it was 18 minutes of
a guy saying I'd like to cancel why
doesn't matter just wants you why please
I'm just looking to terminate why folks
I'm no business expert but I don't think
your customer service experience is
supposed to feel like a car ride with a
four-year-old
and look I I don't mean to pick on
Comcast I'm just using their name
because it's illegal to kill them and of
course you know later they apologized
and said this is not how we train our
customer service representative except
for one tiny detail it's exactly how
they dress they're not in the service
industry they're in the small print
industry and this is the new business
model in America annoying you out of
your money
wearing you down until you're too weak
to complain and then when you just can't
go on and die charge you for early
cancellation or just make something up
and put it on a bill and hope no one
notices what the hell is a resort fee at
a hotel resort fee I went straight to my
room rubbed one out and one for
when was I resorting why because you
have a treadmill it's like going to a
restaurant being charged extra cuz they
have a candle on the table when I just
have been made take a couple of 20s out
of my wallet when she's in the room
we'll call it an undocumented surcharge
or how about the surcharge the airline's
tack on for the privilege of bringing
luggage on a trip
a new survey finds that Americans
airlines are the work of the world's
most profitable and the world's least
comfortable why because they can because
mergers and consolidation and no options
is great for business you know the
flight attendant always says we know you
have many choices narrow lines and I
always think come on honey that line is
older than you are
and that's the problem with the free
market today it's not free or much of a
market what was the last time the
government said no to a merger it's it's
one of those vague memories like lawn
darts or pubic hair Rupert Murdoch wants
to buy the company that owns this
channel at which time this show will
become paste-eating time with Steve
Doocy
Americans need to start recognizing that
big business is the new big government
it is the massive unwieldy bureaucracy
that just doesn't work
goldman sachs may have been too big to
fail but the phone company the credit
card company the mortgage company the
insurance company they're all too big to
care everyone about the post
office but at least there are people
behind the counter there which is more
than I can say for Rite Aid I wandered
around there for thirty minutes the
other night looking for someone to pay
for my cough syrup it's a good thing I
didn't have a cough
my friends on the right have this
unshakeable idea that the free market is
always perfect because it lets consumers
find the best product at the best prices
and that's a nice idea for business
school or at the andron charity haters
club but here in reality Ville what
happens is you get cable from the one
cable company in your city and you sign
a piece of paper and then
Rumpelstiltskin comes to your house and
sodomize is you and laughs I'm kidding
he doesn't come to your house you have
to call